it's time for a good ol relationship oh
yeah we haven't done one of these in a
long time this is the funniest one I've
seen in a minute I read it my 25 male
girlfriend okay 2014 did not appreciate
my reaction to seeing her naked okay
there's currently this trend on the
tic-tock app of girls surprising their
man by walking into the room naked and
filming the reaction I've seen these
videos before and normally the reaction
is the man gets a smile on his face and
they obviously get it on its cheesy
romantic funny
whatever my girlfriend is working from
home during the pandemic and I work in
hospital I got home from a 12-hour shift
of potentially being exposed to Cove in
19 and just wanted some beers and to go
to bed I guess my girlfriend thought she
would get the same reaction when I
walked in the door and saw her naked I
barely had enough energy left to give
any reaction let alone a good one I
basically just told her I appreciated
the gesture but I was exhausted oh she
got moody at me and basically and she
got moody at me basically comparing all
these other tic TOCs where the man gets
excited to see their girl naked I told
her all the technology men working from
home not walking in the door after a
12-hour shift in a hospital during a
pandemic she then took this as an insult
at the fact that she's currently working
from home oh no she's acting like I
don't find her sexy at all and giving me
sarcastic answers what do I even say to
her what a horrible situation for
everyone involved the insecurity is
through the [ __ ] roof on this one
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] dude
I was thinking I would dude I was
thinking about that watching these on
tik-tok I was like imagine how many of
these didn't go the way that they wanted
them to go like for every one that was
posted that was funny and good and had a
lot of likes there's like 30 that didn't
work out that someone walked in the room
naked and the person was like yeah
you don't saying I wanted to do an with
Elena we're like one of two or she walks
in and what like either one I get really
[ __ ] angry like appeared gamer rage
and then put that hole in the drywall
cuz or the second she walks in and I'm
already jerking off to what I don't know
a car this is a car from too fast you
fury and my desk is in standing mode and
my pants are fully on the floor like a
[ __ ] six-year-old peeing at a urinal
the other one David did on tick tock
where Natalie comes out in the towel
throws and drops a just piece yeah
you're just jacking off to a picture of
her naked she's like oh okay
what get out
still upset yeah yeah god damn bro
you're [ __ ] dude gets home he said
he's probably like in the scrubs his
face has got to be on his face you know
that he's [ __ ] exhausted I mean it's
yeah but I don't know at the same time
it's like you can't yeah I mean like
you'd listen I don't think you can like
blame her for like getting naked and
expecting him to like react positively
but I think you can blame her for
[ __ ] filming a tik-tok and expecting
a reaction for the camera yeah yeah you
know when he comes home from a 12-hour
shift of probably the most stressful
work you can do right now and she's
sticking a camera in his face being like
can you just do this for the four
tik-tok for my ticked on feed em hmm
then it's like that's kind of [ __ ] but
if she walks in and she's like hey let
me let me [ __ ] you make this all better
you know then that's not really that a
bad gesture no and then if he's like was
I'm tired I'd I would but let's just do
it tomorrow then that's fine you know
yeah no I mean but it's her bringing a
[ __ ] camera in there and being like
just do this for the for the tick-tock I
guess I blur the two because I feel like
she's only naked because it's tick-tock
yeah yeah yeah that's yeah that's the
same thing but yeah I guess that's where
I do [ __ ] like like I don't know man
that's a bit that's a lot if you come
home from a 12 hour or anything you know
I mean you walk in the door someone's
butt ass naked like let's [ __ ] go
you're like get come on get it get it
Bomi you're like oh no she's like lie
down lie down ground soon I'm a mount
you go yeah yeah starts whipping his leg
speedo you know speaking of come on get
well we go harp on this for a little bit
longer but I just thought this was so
funny that she is being petty towards
him because he didn't want to [ __ ] after
working 12 hours a day that is pretty
wild
that's pretty [ __ ] wild especially to
be on the front lines where you're like
saying people died and [ __ ] all day
you're probably seeing like the most
morbid [ __ ] people dying alone Oh bro
you read any of those stories of like
nurses like having to be the like
basically the in-between for people
dying yeah man they're all getting a
throw getting therapy after this
apparently yeah I'm like PTSD therapy
apparently yeah well how many how I'm
looking people can you sit there and you
know whatever you know we got nurses and
[ __ ] that listen to the show we don't
know we don't want to put them off bro
yeah no I'm just a wait wait we can say
that we can say that we can say that we
can say thank you yeah thank you for
sure how about this though okay
you ready ready yeah we got a [ __ ]
double whammy right here okay okay dude
is is getting kovat treatment right he's
not dying but he's in bad shape and he
looks to the nurse and he's on the
ventilator he's like my girlfriend keeps
trying to FaceTime me can you just
FaceTime her for me
you're the nurse feel like a of course
of course and he face times his girl and
bam his girl is just she's got the phone
setup she's laid back on the bed
butt-ass naked
oh no she's DJing or [ __ ] and you're
like oh wait hold on now
hold on actually it's for tick-tock it's
rich smile baby it's for tick-tock dude
that's the never mind never mind
what I was gonna say that's the next
challenge is own not walking naked
FaceTime naked FaceTime naked and covert
challenge no I was just saying I was
just saying you know you never know
just like I walked in on my oh my oh my
hubby and I was around my wife and I was
jacking off you have to walk in the room
already masturbate masturbate
if it's your partner I think and you
have a mutual level of understanding
yeah that's true that's true even if
you've been with something brother
that's the funny thing is like you know
it's like you know I'm sure if you do
that [ __ ] in the first year or two it's
like cute it's funny if I did that [ __ ]
to Elena right now she would smack my
dick and be like I have to work I get
that [ __ ] [ __ ] out of here man I'm
working get that [ __ ] beauty thing
away from me the [ __ ] peashooter out
of here man all right now stand there
while she's writing an email just like
jerk
she'd be like no yeah nice dick loser
you know as you do that's it she starts
bullying you yeah oh oh that's supposed
to turn me on doesn't turn me on in
eight years
go [ __ ] yourself you're like oh wow
you're you're you walk in it babe drunk
house it's like it's so small I didn't
think it could get any smaller it must
be freezing in here
babe babe what the [ __ ] she just hits
you with a spray bottle no down just get
out out out back in your hole uh that's
funny
deep bro and so you're sitting there I'm
just imagining a nurse holding a [ __ ]
facetime of a girl cuz I can't wait for
you to come always out anyways we should
do though I might I might start the
opposite trend I might walk in the
living room just full snowsuit yeah and
get a reaction
yeah clothed she's called way to clothes
challenge yeah
like you walk in with 50 shirts on but
your dick is still out yeah yeah always
and it's like it's like there's so many
layers it's just the head poking yeah
there's so many boxers on the and it
just doesn't get it to like your
partner's eye with what like come on you
see it it's called the glory hole
challenge
[Laughter]
you